so this is the expected result
of what is happening nationally
with abortion rights and with Roe v Wade
we talked about
last week how this was a concern this
was something that was expected to
happen and now it is happening Texas
hospitals are refusing to see people
with serious pregnancy issues for fear
of violating post-row abortion ban
according to a medical group we talked
about it 10 days ago and much like with
other things people wrote in saying
David that's hypothetical David that's
theoretical well it's now reportedly
happening check this out the Texas
Medical Association says some hospitals
are refusing emergency care for
pregnancy complications they fear
violating the near total abortion ban in
Texas the group said a woman was refused
treatment for her ectopic pregnancy
until it eventually ruptured this is
part of the Dallas Morning News in a
letter to the Texas Medical Board seen
by the newspaper the association said it
received numerous complaints that
hospitals were blocking doctors from
giving pregnant people medically
necessary care
which includes ending a pregnancy
remember that when I first reported on
this some of the responses were David
that's not going to happen because there
are exceptions in these bills and as I
pointed out the medical exceptions in
the Texas abortion Bill really are up to
the discretion of the doctor and can
easily lead to gray area scenarios where
the doctors are afraid of being second
guessed not only by lawyers by but by
politicians sued for the actions that
they decide to take and even if it would
apparently be legal and even if you
fought it and defend yourself and get a
lawyer and ultimately Prevail what
doctor wants to deal with that even if
you believe you will ultimately come up
on the right side of the law do you
really want to be dealing with that for
years because that's how long a lot of
these things will take so the exceptions
explanation is Bogus the article goes on
to say
um according to the paper the letter
described one case of a woman who had an
ectopic pregnancy which allows uh the
pregnancy that grows in the Fallopian
tubes will never be viable but will be
life-threatening she was said to have
been refused treatment until her
pregnancy ruptured when you delay or
prevent care in that scenario it creates
a substantial risk for the patient's
future reproductive ability and poses a
serious risk to the patient's immediate
physical well-being understand that with
this condition
uh doctors know this is not going to
ultimately lead to uh a live Human I I
don't even know the words to use it's
just not and the correct thing in these
situations is to assist in terminating
the pregnancy
um if you don't not only can you put the
a pregnant woman at health risk you can
also jeopardize her ability to even have
future
uh healthy babies and doctors are saying
even though that's the case the risk to
me legally
feels so great that we may and in this
case did refuse treatment the forced
birth people
keep emailing me saying oh you're
fear-mongering about that you're
fear-mongering about that and of course
it's now happening exactly as predicted
and by the way you know for all of the
claims that they are pro-life
when the mother dies if it's before the
fetus is viable the fetus dies too not
exactly pro-life to say two deaths
instead of what they believe to be one
and when you think about what's
happening in Texas it doesn't really
sound like a developed country I mean
zoom out I tweeted about this if I told
you there's a place on this planet it
has a notably higher infant mortality
rate than much of the developed World
talking about Texas doctors are afraid
of treating women with pregnancy
complications because there's crazy
anti-abortion laws inspired by the
religion of the people passing them
which makes the doctors worried they'll
get arrested for providing care talking
about Texas and also they're working in
facilities and hospitals whose power
might go out because they are dependent
on generators in some cases because
they've got this isolated power grid
without redundancy now they have that by
choice not by necessity there are lots
of parts of the world where what I just
described is not by choice most people
would not assume that that's the state
of Texas when I give you those three
things higher than than most of the
developed World infant mortality
um of doctors fearing giving people the
medical treatment they need for fear of
arrest and worries about the power going
out because of an isolated power grid I
don't know what most people would think
but most people would not think that
it's a state in the United States that's
what's going on
in Texas and it's completely predictable
and it wasn't just us predicting it it's
now happening